sens votre retour semble une réussite
pour vous oui bonsoir oui je suis tout à
fait satisfaite du score ce soir puisque
non seulement nous sommes en tête avec
l'équipe mais nous avons fait nous
sommes en tête dans l'ensemble des
bureaux de la ville ce qui est pour nous
un énorme encouragement puisque notre
volonté est de sortir la ville de cette
espèce de marasme qui a agité les
dernières années avec une démission d'un
maire avec une explosion d' équipe qui a
amené six équipes se présentant au
scrutin et qui donne le score de ce soir
ramener l'ordre c'est votre mission ça
va suffire
ah non non non c'est pas ramener l'ordre
c'est la volonté l'ambition de sortir la
ville de cette espèce de marasme pour
lui redonner tout son lustre la place
qui doit être la sienne au coeur du nord
de l'yonne au côté du grand paris enfin
juste à la halle à la frontière du grand
paris et nous avons beaucoup d'ambitions
pour cette ville qui a perdu beaucoup de
temps ces temps ci et c'est dans cet
esprit là que nous allons nous battre
cette semaine parce que si vous voulez
il ne s'agit pas uniquement de gagner
une élection
il s'agit véritablement d'entraîner une
dynamique et la population avec nous il
faut redonner de l'espérance aux
sénonais
il ne vous a pas échappé que
l'abstention aujourd'hui est importante
et toute équipe volontariste et sérieuse
souhaite entraîner une dynamique dont ce
que j'espère c'est que dimanche prochain
non seulement nous gagnerons mais nous
aurons avec nous beaucoup de ces données
je vous répète je suis très satisfaite
des tentes est dans l'ensemble des
bureaux de la ville